[Music]
on this saturday night a twister
turns deadly major tornado here a
powerful tornado touches down in
southwestern manitoba killing two people
and carving a path of destruction
answering the call for help today's
announcement though is really about
focusing on saving lives the canadian
government announces plans to match
donations for disaster relief in beirut
as cries for an international
investigation into the explosion grow
louder
plus tackling your questions about
covid19
i think it's appropriate to have a
little bit of worry we ask the experts
to weigh in
on students returning to school and
choosing the right mask
for children
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
jeff semple
well take a look at this a terrifying
tornado in southwestern manitoba
last night the scale of the twister
caught on camera by storm chasers
police say those powerful winds lifted
vehicles right off the road
and tossed them like toys into a nearby
field
good evening thank you for joining us at
least two people were killed by that
tornado they were driving when the storm
struck and were thrown
right out of their vehicle the twister
touched down at around 8 p.m in this
rural community just south of the town
of verdan
near brandon our joe scarpelli is there
and has the latest
it's been described as scary and
devastating footage captured friday
night shows this twister touching down
in western manitoba
just outside verdan where tammy skelton
lives i'm looking at this thing going
go away go away get out of my yard when
it did leave her yard
she says she followed and watching the
destruction it was leaving behind
she dialed 9-1-1 the lady all i can hear
her saying is
please slow down please so don't i can't
tell what you're saying during that call
she says the twister flipped
two vehicles in front of her one man was
trapped in an suv
he was honking the horn trying to alert
help trying to get someone to come and
get him
they couldn't get to him because the
hydra lines were down the 54-year-old
was taken to hospital with serious
injuries two people were in the second
vehicle police say
they were thrown when the tornado hit
after a bit they started cpr
on the second person and
it's very unfortunate the 18 year olds
were pronounced
dead at the scene just across the street
from this farm property
one of the hardest hit areas dozens of
volunteers
now helping to clean up it's quite bad
we got big trees down we got
bins down basically decimated
there's not much left as pictures and
videos of the tornado circulate online
the town's mayor is warning residents to
stay back
should another powerful storm emerge a
tornado don't fool around with them
one minute it can be going that way and
the next minute it can take you right
with it joel scarpelli
global news now environment canada is
still investigating and trying to
determine exactly how strong that
tornado was
the intensity is measured on what's
called the enhanced fujita scale
now canada has only ever recorded one
tornado that reached ef5 status the most
powerful
and that was also in manitoba back in
2007 that twister ripped through the
town of eli
packing winds of over 420 kilometers an
hour
incredibly no one was killed or
seriously injured canada's deadliest
tornado was way back in 1912
what became known as the regina cyclone
devastated that city
tearing through a residential area and
its downtown killing 28 people
well another twister in edmonton in 1987
was both the second deadliest and the
costliest
ripping through the city and causing
more than 300 million dollars in damage
well turning to the situation in lebanon
now thousands of frustrated protesters
have taken to the streets of central
beirut
they blamed the country's leaders for
tuesday's deadly explosion and they're
demanding justice
at least 158 people were killed in that
blast more than six thousand
injured and dozens are still missing
international aid is now being rushed
into lebanon
including from canada but as mike truly
explains ottawa is not giving that money
to the lebanese government days after an
explosion shook beirut
protesters took to the streets to vent
their anger
police shot tear gas into large crowds
trying to get to the parliament
buildings
undaunted the protesters broke into the
foreign ministry
where they symbolically burned a picture
of lebanese president
michelle aiona this woman said
they'll never forgive the government for
their negligence
it was last tuesday that a warehouse
filled with ammonium nitrate blew up
aeon has rejected calls for an
international investigation
saying lebanon would handle the matter
itself canadian officials were careful
with their words
but their actions spoke volumes no money
will be sent to the lebanese government
instead aid will be funneled to
organizations canada trusts
what we are focused on right now is
responding to the emergency
at hand lebanese canadians have opted
for a similar approach
a group of labor organizers are
encouraging people to donate
to specific charities like the red cross
with proven track records
essentially bypassing the state because
you really don't want to give
legitimacy to a lot of these state
actors and politicians in lebanon
that have no legitimacy and that
perception is not only fueling the
bitterness within lebanon
it could impact how fast aid gets
delivered to those who need it
and unfortunately this is something that
eight agencies
tend to deal with in in many countries
around the world i think the existing
relationships we have with communities
and these
local civil society groups will play a
critical
a critical role in this
with the government hanging on by a
thread it will have to
mike girl at global news toronto
relentless rains are soaking south korea
with little relief in sight
take a look at this dramatic moment when
two rescuers pulled a woman from a
partially submerged car
now fortunately she was brought to
safety but at least 26 others have now
died in heavy flooding and landslides
caused by more than
six weeks of intense monsoon rains the
worst that country has seen in at least
seven years and in india a landslide
that was also caused by heavy monsoon
rain has killed at least
22 people
rescue workers are now searching for
dozens of others believed to be trapped
under the soil and debris
the slide hit overnight while most
people were sleeping and even more rain
is expected to hit the region
and also in india investigators have now
found the so-called black boxes from the
plane that crashed yesterday killing at
least 18 people
the air india express jets skidded off
the runway while trying to land in heavy
rain
both pilots were killed now the flight
recorders may provide some answers as to
what
caused the crash that flight was
repatriating more than 180
indians who were stranded abroad by the
pandemic
officials say it's a miracle that the
death toll wasn't higher
this marks india's worst passenger
aircraft accident since 2010
and an oil tanker stranded on a reef in
the indian ocean
has now sparked an environmental
emergency
new satellite images show tons of oil
leaking from a japanese tanker which ran
aground near the coast of mauritius last
month
the prime minister is urgently calling
for international help saying the small
island nation
lacks the skills or expertise to
re-float stranded ships
mauritius is a popular tourist
destination known for its world-renowned
coral reefs to the pandemic now as the
u.s
nears 5 million confirmed cases of
covid19 a quarter of all infections
worldwide
president trump is now issuing executive
orders to introduce
economic relief for americans that move
comes after talks in congress broke down
this week
with democrats demanding more than a
short-term solution
while republicans claim their demands
amount to a blank check
as jennifer johnson explains the
democrats could take the trump
administration
to court u.s president donald trump says
his executive orders will be the bailout
millions of struggling americans need
to stay afloat during this pandemic
we've had it
and we're going to save american jobs
and provide relief to the american
workers
the president's orders will delay rental
housing evictions
payroll taxes and student loan payments
until the end of the year
and reinstate additional unemployment
benefits which ran out july 31st
for almost 30 million americans i'm
taking action to provide an additional
or an extra four hundred dollars per
week at expanded benefits
four hundred dollars okay
so that's generous but we want to take
care of our people again it wasn't their
fault it was china's fault
less than 100 days until election day
the president blames democrats for the
impasse
their three trillion dollar plan
included most of the benefits but also
more money for covet-19
testing and reopening schools
republicans didn't want to spend more
than a trillion dollars
after nearly two weeks of talks
negotiations were called off late friday
i've told them come back when you when
you
are ready to give us a higher number
democrats have hinted they may sue the
president
saying only congress has the authority
to allocate these funds money millions
of unemployed
say can't come soon enough right now i
have no kind of a lifestyle
i'm just i'm here that's how i feel i
just feel like i'm just here
and i'm lost and i'm scared democrats
still want to make a deal
saying the president's order is just a
short-term fix
for an economic crisis that will last
well into 20-21
jennifer johnson global news washington
a canadian man has died while in the
custody of u.s
immigration authorities james hill
started feeling sick just days before he
was scheduled to be deported
he died in hospital this week from
covid19 and as camille caramali explains
his family
is now demanding answers his name
was james hill but to doug hunt and his
family
he was known simply as uncle jimmy he
was our favorite uncle his kids
and on wednesday night the 72 year old
died in a virginia hospital from
covit 19 alone and scared when he was
supposed to be back home in ontario
surrounded by loved ones it was just so
tragic that he was so close
to coming back for his new life the
physician who studied at the university
of toronto and practiced in louisiana
had served a 13-year sentence for
writing oxycontin prescriptions
without seeing patients he was
technically released in april
but was sent to the farmville detention
center in virginia
to wait out some bureaucratic hurdles
caused by the coronavirus pandemic
before being deported to canada it's run
by u.s
immigration and customs enforcement
known more commonly as
ice what he didn't know is what would
happen there
the center was slammed with coven 19
cases in june
amid complaints of overcrowding and poor
sanitation
in fact some detainees have even filed a
court application
seeking immediate release claiming
they're an imminent risk
of serious illness or death from coven
19.
there have been 290 coronavirus cases at
the virginia facility as of wednesday
that's more than half of the entire
population of the detention center
which currently consists of as many as
400 people
he was terrified of getting covert there
was no physical distancing whatsoever
hill was scheduled to leave july 9 but
the family says he was hospitalized with
covid 19 symptoms
just a week before his deportation date
it was just so
tragic that it was so close you know so
his detention actually became
unlawful just because kovid spread he
should not have been detained by the
eyes
i said it is undertaking a comprehensive
agency-wide review of the incident
but for hunt's family they're hoping
uncle jimmy's story is a lesson
to make sure changes are made at the
virginia facility he begged them to
segregate him and they didn't and now
he's dead
you know i mean that's that's the sad
part that their negligence caused this
kamil caramali global news
coming up our experts answer your kovid
19
questions as schools scramble to reopen
how should parents prepare
their answers next
well for months now global news has been
taking your questions about covet 19 and
the pandemic
straight to the experts and
unsurprisingly a lot of questions lately
have focused on schools in just over
four weeks students across the country
will head back to school
many for the first time since the
pandemic closed classrooms back in march
but is it safe do parents have reason to
worry
for the answers to those and other
questions we are joined now by dr
michael gardum chief of staff at
toronto's humber river hospital
and dr craig jenny from the university
of calgary gentlemen thank you so much
for joining us here
uh dr gotten let's start with you and
let's start with schools
we know students heading back very soon
how worried should parents be about that
do you think
well i think it's appropriate to have a
little bit of worry but the fact remains
we're not the first place doing this
there's been a
number of countries that have brought
kids back to school
and by and large it seems so far to be
working okay although there have
certainly been some small clusters
associated uh with opening schools
and dr jenny to you on that point uh
particularly when we
see images and headlines coming out of
the united states where schools open
and then within hours in the case of one
school in georgia a student tested
positive and students were sent home to
quarantine so
you know should we expect to see scenes
like that playing out in canadian
classrooms
i think the situation here is quite
different so for example we have much
lower virus burden in the community
many fewer people are infected here so
the risk of introducing the virus
is lower um but as echoed uh
earlier we need to still be vigilant we
still have to be paying attention to
this and the situation may change
if we look at the numbers as they exist
right now in canada we can probably
safely open schools
with little concern but those numbers
change and we need to
adjust as we move forward and uh dr
jenny let's start with you on this next
question
about masks any advice to parents though
on how to choose the right mask for your
child
yeah so the masks have to be something
that's comfortable if the kids are
playing with them always adjusting them
taking them off and on
this is really what we want to avoid so
it has to be a mask that the kids are
comfortable with
it's a mask that they want to wear and
there's no harm in starting them on the
mask now
to ensure that when they they go to
school in a couple weeks it's not a
shock to their system
yeah and dr gardum on that point as well
you know this is one certainly we talked
to parents and they kind of roll their
eyes at the expectation that you will be
able to get
large numbers of children to wear masks
for long periods of time i mean does
that even seem realistic in your
assessment well you know what i mean
honestly we're going to find out i mean
but you know
i i think to their point you certainly
can't rely completely on masks you have
to have a number of other strategies
such as you know decreasing the
class size pushing the desks apart etc
the masks are really only
one component and you know we'll find
out very quickly
how easy it's going to be for uh
students to be able to do this
obviously the older they get presumably
the easier it will be all right dr
michael gardum dr craig jenny don't go
anywhere because we're going to take a
quick break when we come back
we're going to bring you some of our top
questions from viewers about covid19 and
the pandemic
stay with us
welcome back we are speaking with dr
michael gardum chief of staff
at humber river hospital in toronto and
dr craig jenny
from the university of calgary taking
your covid19 questions
straight to the experts and this
question comes from denise
redinger who asked that if my child is
in a classroom where another child
tests positive for covid19 and is then
told to self-isolate for 14 days
does that mean our whole house has to
isolate for 14 days and
should i inform my employer dr jenny
so this is a tough question it's
important to remember that the
self-isolation is
different than the formal quarantine
that we have for example travelers
coming across an international border
so self-isolation you are able to still
go out for essential services if
necessary
the goal here is to limit the spread so
if if a child is suspected to come in
contact with a classmate
we want them to stay home until we can
determine whether they're positive or
negative
but the parents in the house for example
can still go to work
but this is also where those
recommendations of wearing a mask come
in if there's a risk that you
two are infected and you wear a mask
you're going to greatly reduce that risk
in the community until you know for sure
whether your child has been exposed the
really difficult part is if kids have to
stay home and parents have to work
often the child care duties then fall on
other people such as grandparents who
may be
very much at risk if the child has
brought a virus home and our last viewer
question
uh to you michael garden comes from
stephen and cliff who asks what
percentage of the canadian population
would need to be vaccinated
to open our borders to international
travelers once again
great question we would all love to know
the answer to that we have to assume
that we have a vaccine and the vaccine
actually
works well but presided that that's true
uh
you know looking at the relative
percentage of the population to actually
achieve that so-called herd immunity
where the virus really can't spread very
well
that's a wide number right now people
haven't really nailed that down i've
seen numbers anywhere from 20
of us protected up to 80 percent of us
protected and everywhere in between
part of the reason the u.s border is
closed right now is because
the virus is really spreading largely
unchecked in the u.s
and so they need to get their house in
order before i think canadians are going
to feel comfortable opening the
international border
yeah and i think you know if you ask
canadians what scares the most about the
pandemic right now it is what's
happening south of the border and the
headlines and images we see
coming out of there every day now dr
michael gardum
dr craig jenny gentlemen thank you so
much for helping us to answer some of
those questions from viewers really
appreciate it
thank you you're welcome and if you have
any questions about covid19
here's how to get in touch email your
questions at globalnews.ca we'll put
them to the experts and bring you the
answers right here on global national
that is global national for this
saturday i'm jeff semple tonight your
canada is the big
sheep wandering the hillside in okanagan
falls in bc
thanks for watching have a great night